swathi i am so excited to be talking to
you today but i will say
a lot of people myself included were
really sad to see your torch snuffed but
thank you for joining us this morning
uh
i'm so excited to be
here all right so let's get down to it
the votes are read
were you surprised with how the votes
went and what do you think went wrong
um no i wasn't surprised in that moment
at all i think um the night before the
immunity challenge was sort of when a
lot of things went down and um so so i i
knew pretty much if we were going to
tribal it was very likely to be me and i
would say probably what went down is
when i told tori that she was on the
bottom i think that was sort of my
critical mistake because if you tell
somebody that they're on the bottom like
obviously they're going to panic um
which i think is sort of what happened
i can't really fault her for that i
think maybe i should have it's not a
thing that i even intended to say going
into the conversation and it's maybe a
thing i should have thought more about
before saying
well it seemed like on your tribe there
was a lot of back and forth a lot going
on before you went to tribal council
and we saw that you were the third
person to use the shot in the dark this
season so was there a specific moment
either at camp or at tribal which made
you
know that you needed to play your shot
in the dark
yeah i would say um
i would probably played it anyway with
the uncertainty because i just i knew
that um
it wouldn't have made really a
difference in the outcome um if people
were going to side with me but
it was like 30 minutes before tribal i
thought drea and romeo had decided to
vote with me and then draya comes up to
romeo and she says something like oh
like can we talk or either maybe oh
let's change the plan
and that's the moment where i knew
because like i had gotten the vibes like
okay they were going to side with me
that they were going to vote with me
um
and
uh
yeah it was it was this sort of that i
was like
like
we saw this amazing montage last night
of you telling drea romeo and tori that
you were their number one and as i'm
watching it every time a new one came up
i'm like oh no swappy what's happening
so can you share some more insight into
that strategy and who was actually your
number one
yeah i would say that um
my number one was probably rocks and
then probably tori it was it wasn't um
drea or romeo which i think uh learning
that i'd said this tutorial was probably
the big thing that set romeo andrea off
was was realizing that i actually really
really did want to work with her um but
i would also say in my defense romeo had
been telling me i was his number one
from like day one which is the only
reason i said it to him and i think
draya had said it's me also just like
two seconds before that clip that was
aired so um it wasn't it wasn't a thing
that only i was doing because like i was
in either romeo or dre is number one it
was sort of something that everybody on
our tribe was doing but i think
the big things are like one realizing
that i said it to tori um and then two i
think people just didn't think that i
was playing the game as hard as
everybody else so i think realizing all
at once like oh that i've been doing all
this stuff
just made me look very suspicious like i
i think like people bought the innocent
thing a little bit a little bit too much
that's the hard thing about this game
right because i think it's
it's very common for people to tell a
lot of people that someone is their
number one but i think it's when they
actually believe you
it that's a good thing but then that can
also cause some problems
but it's nice to hear that you and
roxroy had a great relationship and i
think that there was that moment at
tribal council where he had pointed out
your growth and how proud he was of you
so what were you thinking in that moment
i mean i just thought it was very sweet
i thought rox was an amazing dude um and
yeah i thought i thought it was very
sweet that he stood up for me at that
tribal
and he actually voted for tori so this
was the first
shot in the dark where it wasn't a
unanimous vote so can you provide some
insight into why rox roy voted the way
he did
well yes because me and rox were
me and rocks were working together and
we were working together more closely
than anybody else
and so he didn't want to flip on me so
he voted the way he said he was going to
vote even if at least my analysis of it
is like even knowing that like i might
be the one going home he said he voted
the way he said he was going to vote
even if it might put him on the house
no it's a terrible thing to do
it's nice to know that even out there
you have some real allies so speaking of
allies that can be real or not so real
so i want to get into your relationship
with tori because
we see you start the episode saying that
tori is someone you want to work with
and then by the end of the episode you
are really pointing the finger at her at
tribal council so do you think that the
relationship you had with tori was
genuine and can you share more about
where she kind of fit into the tribe
yeah i mean i would say that
it was genuine like i really did want to
try and work with her especially because
we were the two youngest on the tribe at
that point um
i would say that i think tori had a
pretty negative relationship with
everybody else on the tribe
um
but i mean yeah i know she knows she
detori like i understand why she acted
the way she acted even if it was very
unfortunate for me
and when you were a tribal council and
you were making it very clear that you
wanted to to put the blame on tori and
to put the pressure on tori what were
you trying to achieve in that moment
well so like i mentioned i had that
moment right before tribal where i saw
drea change the plan with romeo and
given that i've been getting really good
vibes before i was like oh that's that's
a bad sign that is a bad sign
so i was really trying to prompt someone
to change their mind at tribal um
i
yeah i mean i think i would have felt
really
sort of just let events run their course
without at least trying for some sort of
last minute switch
well i mean you're out there you've
already survived the quarantine you
survived the first few days so you have
to do what you can to stay in there
and you mentioned at tribal that no
matter how long your survivor journey
was you'd be processing it for months or
years later and we know that you
actually played the game and filmed the
show months ago so how are you feeling
about your survivor experience now
i mean i'm i'm feeling good i i don't
wanna
i'm feeling good i feel like um
i learned a lot from the experience
and i grew a lot as a person and i was
so grateful for it that i got to go out
and do it um i will say that like
a lot happened to me right before and a
lot happened to me right after in the
sense like i just joined the military
and then since then i've gone on to my
first semester of college and
so
i
don't
i can't really point
as clearly as i would like to be like i
can point the same things in the show
and lessons i've taken away it's hard
for me to point specifically to like oh
this is how i've changed
definitively as a person just because of
that but i mean like yeah i feel like
i'm less obsessed with control for one
thing from the show i think one thing
that i learned last night was like oh
like i think i underestimate the extent
to which people like like me or like
wanna
work with me or be friends with me or et
cetera um
because like it i don't think i
genuinely process it like oh like trey
and roger like actually for real one
i think a lot of people liked you when i
asked people about what i should ask you
about on twitter so many people just
thought that you were a great role model
and i think that you are a remarkable
person and i think that survivor is just
going to be one little thing on
your list of achievements throughout
your life
so i've got to ask you know now that
you're going to be watching the show
from home
who are you rooting for to win survivor
42
um
uh i mean roxroy like
then my man who stood up for me or like
um
if i had a time machine i could bring
the jack back zach
um
yeah
no it's good to know that the
relationships last beyond the game so
swathi thank you so much for chatting
with us hopefully you could be like
either boston rob or rob c whichever rob
of your choice and we can see you at all
stars again but thank you for chatting
and i wish you all of the best
thank you so much
you